ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد هذه التغطيه
مستمره على العربيه للتطورات المتسارعه في
السودان تابعنا التفاصيل تابعنا كذلك مع
مراسلينا ومع ضيوفنا تداعيات وتاثيرات هذه
التطورات
[موسيقى]
اذا للشبكه متواصله في الخرطوم وفي مناطق
عده في السودان اليوم الثالث على التوالي
وفي اخر التطورات اعلن مصدرهم في الجيش
السوداني ان تهديدا للمناطق الحيويه في
العاصمه قد انتهى مشيرا الى انه يجري
التفاهم او يجري التفاهم مع عناصر قوه
الدعم السريع في مقر التلفزيون والقصر
للخروج دون قتال كما اكد المصدر القضاء
على القوه الرئيسيه لمواصفه بالتمرد في
الخرطوم وشدد على ان العاصمه ستكون خاليه
من التمرد خلال اقل من ثمان واربعين ساعه
نتابع هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا عبر الهاتف
يوسف عزت المستشار السياسي لنائب رئيس
مجلس السياده وقائد قوات الدعم السريع
اهلا بك معنا سيد يوسف الى هذه التغطيه
المستمره على قناه العربيه للتطورات في
السودان في الواقع كنا خلال هذا اليوم
نتحدث عن فترات من الحذر الشديد ولكن تعود
الاشتباكات وربما اعنف من ذ هل نتوقع ان
تشتد هذه الاشتباكات في ظل مبادرات
اقليميه ودوليه لمحاوله طرح النزاع في هذه
الفتره
نعم الاشتباكات مستمره
لكن التوقيت الان بالنسبه للمبادرات نحن
نرحب بكل مبادره لكن
انا اتحدث معك كمان المعرفه
هنالك
توقيت
للمعركه نحن ندخل معركه فاصله مع
الانقلابيين مع الاسلاميين مع الذين
اختطفوا القرار في الجيش نحن نسيطر الان
على القياده العامه بالكامل بكل
مبانيها وخارج اسوارها نحن متواجدين نسيطر
على مطار الخرطوم نسيطر على القصر الرئاسي
نسيطر على ايداء امرنا ازاله الاذاعه
والتلفزيون نسيطر على قائده سيدنا الجويه
نسيطر على جبل اولياء مسيطر على كل
المداخل الكباري المؤديه الى ولايه
الخرطوم الى مدينه الخرطوم من الناحيتين
الان بعد الهدنه دخلنا هدنه لمده ساعتين
ولكن تم تلتزم القوات المسلحه بالهدنه
فقط ان اسال عن هذه الهدنه ملتزمون بهذه
الهدنه دعم السريع ملتزم بهذه الهدنه
دعم سريع ملتزمين واضح لكل المحاور لكل
القوات في كل مكان التزام بالهدنه ويسهلنا
مرور المدنيين عبر الكبائر التي نسيطر
عليها كل المرضى الذين يريدون المستشفيات
الحركه بين
الاسرمان تريد تاتي الى الخرطوم هنالك
تعبر الى الخرطوم للم شمله كل هذا فيه
ولكن فوجئنا
باطلاق نار وبقوات كانت منصحبه عادت
لتهاجم والان تدور معارك لم نسمح لهم عبور
الكباري ولكن ايضا
سنتعامل مع المدنيين بحذر لانه لا يمكن
تعريف حياتهم للخطر هذه هي الاوضاع
الراهنه داخل داخل الخصم بالنسبه لمطار
الخرطوم تحدث منذ قليل قلت بانكم سيطرتم
عليه ولكننا تابعنا تصريحات متباينه نفهم
بان هناك سيطره وفيما بعد
محاوله لاسترجاع او فقدتم السيطره عليه
لفترات مستمره وهناك اشتباكات متتاليه على
مستوى هذه النقطه تحدث
لا لا نحن سيطرنا على مطار الخرطوم الدولي
منك الامر
ولا توجد اي خطوره على استرداده او اي
قدره على استرداد هي لان الدعم السريع
لديه وجود شرك المطار وغرب المطار وحتى
داخل القياده كل الشوارع المؤديه الى شارع
المطار لا توجد اي محاوله لاستردادي هنالك
قوه كانت مستحبه من القياده اطلقت نار
كثيف اطلقت اطلاق نار كثيف على المطار
ارجع بعد الحريق ولكن يستطيع ان يسيطر
عليه جميع المسافرين الذين كانوا عالقين
في المطار قم بامان وفرنا لهم كل الامداد
اللازم لا يوجد اي شيء مزعج في مطار
الخرطوم ولا نستطيع استرداد وماذا عن مقر
التلفزيون سيد يوسف هل هناك
سيطرنا على مقر الاذاعه والتلفزيون وبسنه
ثلاثه بيانات من الاذاعه الى جماهير الشعب
السودان تم قطع الارسال من من المحطه
الرئيسيه للارسال في اتحاد وتم بس تحويل
البث الى هناك وجاري
او مركز اخر هنالك
كان هناك حديث عن
تفاهم بينكم وبين الجيش السوداني لمحاوله
الخروج على الاقل او اخلاء مقر التلفزيون
دون قتال هل هذا صحيح
لا يوجد اي تفاهم بيننا لا يوجد اي تطابق
الان بيننا وبين الجيش نحن كل المغاره
التي نسيطر عليها نحكم عليها سيطرتنا لا
يوجد اي
تواصل او تفاهم هذه كلها دعايه حرب الجيش
العام ليس لديه قياده الان البرهان مختفي
كل القيادات ورموز الجيش مختفيه الجيش
الان يتحرك بدون خطه
حين الانسحاب حين نعاود هنالك اعتقال نحن
استطيعنا في العياده العامه لاحتقال عدد
رتبه فريق وادنى كعدد من اللواءات عدد من
القناصه مع اعلان سيطرنا على هذه المشهد
على القياده لا يوجد اي قياده سيطره لانه
السيطره واداره العمليات كانت داخل
الزياده العامه الان الجيش فاقد البوصله
فاقد للتوجيهات فاقد للثوره وفاقد للخطه
هنالك طبعا ما تقولونه سيد يوسف ولكن كذلك
في المقابل واسمح لي ان انقل لك بعض
تصريحات الجيش السوداني هم يقولون بانه
بالعكس انتم تخسرون اتباعكم وهناك حتى من
بعض ضباطكم من استسلموا ومن انضموا الى
الجيش السوداني
لا يوجد اي انضمام للجسد السوداني هنالك
ضباط منتدبين من الجيش يعملون بالقوات
المسلحه عندما كنا نعمل هو التنسيق
التدريب
في كل شيء هنالك ضباط منتدبين تم في اليوم
الاول وهو ما تم ابلاغهم بانهاء انتدابهم
السريع
قبل بدا العمليات انهم يتم بلغوا لغايه
لغايه انهم
انهم تسلموا اوامر بالعوده الى القوات
المسلحه او لا نحترمهم عمل في الدعم
السريع لفتره فتره طويله هم لكنهم يتبعون
للجيش بالنسبه لضباط الدعم السريع
الموجودين الان لا يوجد ولا ضابط واحد كل
الضباط الذين
اخراجهم في الميديا انه هم ضباط تتبعون
للقوات المسلحه وبرهان قبل قبل قبل هجومه
علينا امرهم بالعوده وكثيرين من الضباط
ضباط الضباط الجيش ما قالوا موجودين معنا
ورفض
هنالك تصوير وفبركه
عود من الدعم السريع سلموا اعدادهم وسلموا
للجيش هذه كلها عمليات
كثيرهم
يونيفورم الدعم السريع ويصورونهم بالفيديو
لكسر الروح المعنويه قوات الدعم السريع
وقواتها وتعمل الخطه تعرف نقطه ولكن
فيديو الحقيقه سنتثبت منطقه وصحته ولكن
وددت تعليقك على هذا الفيديو الذي يقول
ناشروه بانه يتحدث او على الاقل يصور
استهداف منزل حميدتي
ماذا في تفاصيل هذا الفيديو
بجانب القياده العامه وهو ليس استهدافه
ليس من اليوم من اليوم الاول بدا استهداف
منزل اللايف من من عماره مجاوره بالقناصه
بعض القنابل داخل البيت ولكن لم يكن
النائب متواجد داخل البيت
تؤكد بانه هذا الفيديو هو فعلا استهداف
منزل حمادتي
هذا ما قلته منذ قليل ولكنه لم يكن حاضر
صحيح
لا لم يكن موجودا ونحن نستطيع ان استطاعت
قوات الدعم البريئه السيطره على مبنى
المخابرات على
صحه على المباني المجاوره استطاعت
اعتقال 42 قناص كان تم نشرهم حول حول
البيت حول المنطقه التي يتحرك فيها الغاز
هذا قبل بدء الهجوم كلهم تم القبض عليهم
وتم تحديد المنطقه بالكامل لان احنا
استلمنا حتى بيت برهان داخل الزياده
العامه اللي هو جاب البيت اللاعبي فلما كل
المنطقه
منذ فتره كانت هناك خلافات بين البرهان
وحمادتي مع حفظ الالقاب لماذا طرح الخيار
العسكري سيد يوسف لماذا وصلتم الى هذا
الحد من التصادم
نحن لم نصل نحن لم نكن طرفا في الحرب
لعمليه سياسيه توقيع على الاتفاق تم
التوقيع على ورقه مسوده للاصلاح والدمج
والتحديث تم كل شيء خطه متفق عليها وهي
خطه اصلا البرهان هو الذي اعلن انسحاب
المؤسسه العسكريه واربعه سبعه من العمليه
السياسيه وطرح تسليم نحن اخذنا الامر
بجديه مشكله البرهان انه كان يناور انها
نوع من التاثير
ولما وصلنا هذه المرحله سيد يوسف تخطيتم
هذه المرحله واخر اخر اخر حديث فقط صحيح
صحيح فقط اسمح لي اخر حديث للجيش السوداني
قال بانه انتم من توسعتم في مرويه انتم
كنتم حاضرون في نقاط لا يمكن لكم ان
تتمركزوا فيها في منطقه مروي ما استفز
الجيش السوداني
نبيض في الدبه بالشماليه في نهر النيل
لماذا مروي
احنا نوجد متواجد في كل مناطق لدينا فيها
معسكر لدينا فيها مباني ان احنا منطقه
معروفه من نقاط الدعم السريه
وحتى القائد العام للجيش يعلم ان الدعم
السريع الذي معسكر يجب ان تسلمه ويستمر
هذه ذريعه اتخذها البرهان لتصوير وجودنا
كانه وجود غير طبيعي
متواجد فيها هذه دعايه محاوله ادخالك
كانها سبب لحرب او كانها سبب لا يوجد اي
شيء يمنعنا من الانتشار او التواجد في اي
منطقه في السودان بالنسبه لنا صحيح هذا ما
تقول حضرتك الجيش السوداني في المقابل
يقول بانه اطلاق اول رصاصه اتى منكم لانكم
اخفقتم في الوصول الى اتفاق لانكم لم
تودوا الوصول الى عمليه الدمج التي
ستخسركم امتيازاتكم ما دقت هذه التصريحات
هذا كلام فارغ وليس له اي اساس من الصحه
نحن اكثر من دعمنا العمليه السياسيه ونحن
وافقنا على الدمج وقعنا عليه ويخرج جداول
زمنيه اتفق عليها هذه عمليه وشكلنا لجنه
مع الجيش من ثلاثه لواءات فنيه لمناقشه
هذه ليست القضيه يا اختي انا اقول لك ولكن
نحن نوافق على الدم اسمح لي سيد يوسف لم
تتفقوا على
وقعنا على الدمج واتفقنا عليه والمتبقي هو
ال ال الاصلاح
الاتفاق على جداول الزمنيه هذه قضيه كلها
يتخذها البرهان درايه والبرهان نحن نواجه
كلاب البرهان كان يعيد الانقلاب وبالتنسيق
مع الحركه الاسلاميه ولدينا ما يثبت
البرهان هذه العمليه التي نواجهها الان
والحرب مجرد جيش السوداني لحرب هي حرب
يحركها التنظيم الاسلامي هو الذي على
ولكن بعد كل هذا يتطورات الجيش السوداني
بدا يسميكم بالحركه المتمرده ما تعليقك
على ذلك
الجيش يمكن ان يقول اي شيء نحن لسنا
متمردين اولا هو الذي هاجمنا في البدايه
وهو الذي جرنا للمعركه وهو الذي كان يعد
ليست الجيش كله ولكن قياده الجيش بالتعامل
مع الاسلاميين
كانوا يريدون الانفراد بالسلطه اخر بعد ان
استغلوا الجيش في 89 الان يستغل الجيش في
معركه
للسيطره والانفلات بالحكم وللعوده للحكم
نحن الان نواجه هذا وحدنا كغوات كما
استهدافا وتم جرنا لمعرفه وتم جر الجيش
لنفس المعركه لفرض الراي او سلطه سلطه
تنتمي لتنظيم محدد ويتشال العمليه
السياسيه الجاريه هذه هذا هو هذه هذا هو
الحقيقي للحرب
يوسف عزات المستشار السياسي لنائب رئيس
مجلس السياده وقائد قوات الدعم السريعه
الى ذلك مشاهدينا نقلت شبكه سينان عن رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني والقائد العام
للجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان قوله ان الهجوم
الذي شنته قوه الدعم السريع في الايام
الاخيره محاوله انقلاب واضاف البرهان ان
قائد قوه الدعم السريع محمد حمدان تمرض ضد
الدوله واذا تم القبض عليه ستتم محاكمته
امام القضاء
[موسيقى]
واليوم الثالث على التوالي تواصلت المعارك
بين قوات الدعم السريع وقوات الجيش
السوداني الاقتتال انتشر في مختلف ارجاء
السودان سيم العاصمه الخرطوم وسط تضارب
للانباء حول مواقع السيطره كل طرف
رقعه المعارك تتسع في السودان عده مواقع
باتت مسرحا للاقتتال سواء داخل العاصمه
الخرطوم او خارجها فخريطه الصراع مليئه
بالنقاط الساخنه اكثر المعارك شراسه تدور
رحاها بالعاصمه الخرطوم ابرزها مقر
القياده العامه للجيش والذي يوجد في شمال
العاصمه فالاقتتال مستمر في محيط مقر
القياده وسط انباء متضاربه حول جهه
المسيطره على المبنى مبنى اخر في العاصمه
الخرطوم تحول الى ساحه صراع بين الطرفين
وهو مبنى القصر الجمهوري الذي يوجد في
المنطقه الشماليه من العاصمه ولا يزال
الوضع غير واضح هناك فقوه الدعم اعلنت
سيطرتها عليه قبل ان ينفي ذلك الجيش
السوداني شمالا دائما لكن هذه المره في
الضفه الاخرى من نهر النيل وتحديدا ام
درمان حيث دارت اشتباكات في محيط مبنى
التلفزيون بعد محاوله قوات الدعم السريع
السيطره عليه لكن الشاشه السوداني اعلن
فيما بعد سيطرته على المبنى بشكل كامل
مجهضا محاولات قوات الدعم وبعيدا عن
العاصمه الخرطوم وهذه المره في شمال
البلاد وتحديدا في مدينه مرويا التي شهدت
اندلاع الشراره الاولى للازمه فمصير مطار
ماروي الذي يقع في الجزء الشرقي من
المدينه لا يزال معلقا في ظل اعلان كل طرف
بسطه سيطرته عليها والاكيد ان حرب المدافع
والاسلحه في السودان توازيها حرب معلومات
اسلحتها المقاطع المصوره والبيانات
وسام الذهبي العربيه
نتابع هذا الموضوع مع ضيفتنا من القاهرات
من الحسين مديره تحرير صحيفه الاهرام
والمختصه في شؤون الافريقيه اهلا بك معنا
سيده اسماء سيده اسماء من خلال كل ما
نتابعه من تطورات ومن خلال متابعاتك كذلك
لهذا يتطورات وما شابهها من نزاعات ما
السنروهات المرتقبه لمثل هكذا تصعيد
اهلا وسهلا التحيه لك ولكل الساده
المشاهدين الكرام
السودان اليوم يقف في مفترق طرق بالفعل
وامامه اما طريق نجاه والذي يبدا بوقف
اطلاق النار
وجلوس الاطراف معا وتوصل الى تفاهمات تفضي
الى حل الازمه والبحث عن مخرج امن لها
واما طرق اخرى تتفاوت ما بين يعني
الحرب الشامله التي
تتمدد لانحاء البلد
يعني يزداد فيها التصعيد
مخاوف حقيقيه على وحده البلد وما اذا كان
سيؤدي ذلك الى فوضى او لا قدر الله او الى
اي سيناريوهات كارثيه لا يامل احد ابدا لا
في السودان ولا في المنطقه ولا الاقليم
والعالم
يذهب السودان الى هذا المسار الغير سلمي
لانه عواقبه لن تكون وخيمه على السودان
وحده وانما على المنطقه العربيه والقاره
الافريقيه وسلم واستقرار العالم كله نعم
السيده اسماء سعود لك بعد قليل بعد
التفكير ببعض الاخبار لتوصل حيث نشرات قوه
دعم السريع صورا لمقاله انه سيطرتها على
صواريخ بمخازن التصنيع الحربي فيما نفع
الجيش هذا الامر وقال ان الصواريخ غير
جاهزه وهي للعرض فقط
نسال الله السلامه والخبث للبلاد والعباد
ان شاء الله
نوعيه من جديد ونذكر بهذا الفيديو هذا
الفيديو اذا الذي كنا نتابعه منذ قليل
حيث ينشر دعم سريع هذه الصور ويقول انه
السيطره او قواته سيطره على صواريخ بمخازن
التصنيع الحربي فيما اتت تصريحات اخرى
مقابل للجيش
السوداني تقول بان هذه الصواريخ هي
بالاساس صواريخ لم تبدا او لم نبدا في
استعمالها
تصريحات متباينه بين طرفين شاهدناها منذ
بدء هذه الازمه ومنذ بدا الصراع في داخل
السوداني اعود الى ضيفي من القاهره اسماء
الحسيني مديره تحرير صحيفه الاهرام
والمختصه في شؤون الافريقيه سيده اسماء قد
تكون النزاعات الاهليه هي الاصعب لانها
تكون عاده خاليه من اي حسابات اقليميه او
دوليه وبالتالي حلها يكون اصعب الحروب
الاهليه يكون تكون حلولها اصعب في هذه
الحاله من الطرف القادر ان يضغط على الاقل
على الاطراف لمحاوله التهدئه وتسبيق الح
السياسيه على الحلول العسكريه
نعم يعني الحرب فعلا في السودان الان دخلت
منعطف خطير كل طرف من الطرفين يتمترس خلف
مواقفه ويرون في هذه المعركه ومعركه تكسير
عظام وكل طرف يريد ان يعزز موقفه قبل ان
يتم الضغط عليه من اجل الدخول في اي
مفاوضات او وقف لاطلاق النار وانا في رايي
انه الاطراف او الطرف الذي يمكن ان يضغط
على السودان ليس طرفا واحدا وانما يمكن ان
يكون مجموعه اطراف في الاقليم والمجتمع
الدولي هناك دول ترتبط بالطرفين بعلاقات
متميزه في الاقليم وايضا هناك دور للاتحاد
الافريقي لجامعه الدول العربيه للقوه
الدوليه المؤثره وللامم المتحده اعتقد ان
هناك حاجه للجهد مشترك من اجل ممارسه ضغوط
قويه على الطرفين لانهم لن يستجيبان
للنداءات والمناشدات من اجل وقف اطلاق
النار وانما يحتاجان الى ضغوط قويه ومكثفه
عاجله حتى يتحقق وقت اطلاق النار المرجو
نعم اود شكرك جزيل الشكر من القاهره اسمها
الحسين مديره تحرير صحيفه الاهرام
والمختصه في شؤون الافريقيه
في نفس هذا الاطار قالت البعثه الامميه في
السودان ان الاليه الثلاثيه تحث قيادتي
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع على
الالتزام بالهدنى اليوم مؤكده ان الهدنه
الانسانيه ستوفر فرصه للسماح للمدنيين في
مناطق النزاع بالحصول على المساعده او
الخروج بامانه
مشاهدينا يضم الجيش السوداني عددا من
القاده البارزين برئاسه الفريق اول عبد
الفتاح البرهان كما تضم قوه دعم السريع
التي راسها محمد حمدان دقلو ونائبه وشقيقه
عبد الرحيم حمدان ضبا ومستشارين نتعرف
عليهم
[موسيقى]
اناقش كل هذه التطورات مع ضيفنا هنا في
الاستوديو دكتور اسامه احمد المصطفى كاتب
ومحلل في الشؤون الافريقيه اهلا بك معنا
دكتور هذه التغطيه المستمره من العربيه في
الواقع اليوم نحن امام تصريحات متباينه من
الطرفين سواء فيما يخص السيطره او كذلك
حتى فيما يخص قراءه الاحداث اليوم عبد
الفتاح البرهان على سينان قال بانه من
اطلق او رصاصه هم الدعم السريع بهدف
الانقلاب ولكن كان معنا المستشار السياسي
لدعم السريع واكد لنا بان الجيش السوداني
هو الذي بدا بتصعيد الموضوع عسكريا وهدفه
كان افشال العمليه السياسيه اي الروايتين
تصدق اكثر
هذه من المفارقات التي ستؤذن المساله اكثر
المستشار الاستاذ عزت
من واشنطن الذي او من امريكا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هو مستشار
انت تعتقد بانه هذا التصعيد هو بهدف افشل
العمل السياسيه او هو بهدف الانقلاب كما
يقول جيش السوداني
الامر المهم جدا هو الان حرب اعلاميه من
الطرفين
قوات العسكريه قوات الشعب المسلحه لحد
الان
النبره الاعلاميه لديهم ضعيفه مقابل
النبره الاعلاميه لدى حركه من قوات الدعم
السريع ظهور على الاعلام التصريحات كما
راينا تصريحات يوسف عزت بالمقابل لها في
لدى قوات الشعب المسلحه ليس هناك تصريحات
واضحه ليس مخاطبه لوجدان الشارع السوداني
بشكل جيد كما يخاطبون
مجموعه قوات الدعم السريع للوجدان
السوداني الا يعود ذلك لتركيبه كل فريق
الفريق الاول نتحدث عن جيش نظامي كلامه
محسوب تصريحاته محسوبه والثاني معرف على
انه ميليشيات ربما الواقع يفرض يعني وضع
جديد في نحن في في وقت يتطلب من كل
الاطراف مخاطبه الشارع
بمفاهيم تعزز فكره نحن معكم ولين ولسنا
ضدكم كما
يقول السيد محمد حمدان الشارع انه انا ما
عندي ديمقراطي انا هذا يعني استثاره
لعطفهم تجاهي وهذا يفقده الجيش في الوقت
الراهن وانه الوقت الراهن هم قوات الجيش
قوات الشعب المسلحه من باب اولى ان القوات
الشعب المسلحه هي تخاطب الشعب اكثر من
قوات الدعم السريعه اللي هي قوات اصلا
داعمه لقوات القوات الشعب المسلحه
دكتور اذا كنت بالامس اكدت لي بان
الفريقان لا يملكان قاعده شعبيه بالنظر
الى معاشه السودان من حرب اهليه
وتداعياتها خاصه تاثر بها ولا يريد العوده
لها نعم الواقع
[موسيقى]
الوضع هذا حيخلق ازمه للوسطاء
الوسطاء اذا كان الوسطاء داخليين يعني
سودانيين فيما بينهم ثم الوسطاء الاقليمين
وسطاء الدوليين يكون هنالك مساله
ستكون المساله مبهمه او كيف يقدمون
افكارهم التي يمكن تنقذ الموقف وترفع سقف
ولكن دكتور الم تكن تركيبه القوه القوتين
معروفه منذ البدايه بمعنى ان الجيش
السوداني معروفه تركيبته معروفه عناصر
ومعروفه كذلك حتى الدوله العميقه بداخله
وقوه الدعم السريع معروف تاسيسه من
ميليشيات جويد معروف انتماءه بعض المناطق
لماذا
كانت هناك مرحله من التطور مرحله من
الجلوس على نفس الطاوله والحديث وكانه
هناك خلافات بدات
يعمل على تدليلها وفجاه انفجر الموضوع
الاكيد بان هناك حسابات او ان الاستفاده
من هذا الوقت الذي جلس فيه الطرفين
التفاوض نعم يمكن اشرنا في في
الحديث السابق ان هنالك من
يرغب في سحب البساط من
المدنيه في السودان في المرحله الحاليه
ليس الى الابد ولكن لمرحله ما لظرف ما يجب
على المدنيين ان لا يكونوا موجودين على
مشهد السياسي في السودان باعتبار اخفقتهم
الكثيره التي نحن نشهدها ليس فقط الان منذ
استقلال السودانيه الان حتى الانقلابات
العسكريه التي كانت تحدث في السودان كانت
باعاز من الاحزاب السياسيه نفسها اذا
تحرك البرهان وانا هذا اقول هذا الكلام
ولانه اتابع المشهد البرهان لا يرغب في
يعني كم هو اشار لانه
يرغب في تسليم السلطه المدنيين وكرر هذا
الامر كثيرا ولكن
التصرف الاخير اللي هو سبق
الانفجار اللي حصل بين الطرفين الاربعه
ايام الاخيره كان واضح جدا هو لا يرغب في
ان اعتقد بان عبد الفتاح البرهان مع حفظ
الالقاب عرقله وصول الطرفين الاتفاق نهائي
يمهد لحكم مدني
هذه استفاد من زريعه التحرك الحركه الامين
قوه الدعم السريع التي نحن نعرف هي منتشره
في كل السودان بما فيها مروي التي هي كانت
شراره
الانفجار الذي حصل في السودان ولكن
نرجع نقول انه القوات
عفوا اقصد هنا
التيارات السياسيه نفسها انا اليوم استمعت
رئيس حزب الامه
القومي يا سيد
نذكر اسمه لكن
طالب طالب بان يكون هنالك تدخل نعم
طالب انه كنت تدخل او وساطه خارجيه في
الوقت الراهن فيما هو رئيس حزب الامه
السوداني اكبر حزب في السودان وهو طبعا من
البيوتات كان بامكاني هو
وقيادات الاحزاب السودانيه الموجوده
بالاضافه لقياسيه يكونوا لجنه او جسم
للوساطه هم الاولى بهذا الامر ليس انت
رئيس حزب وتطالب بان يكون في وساطه خارجيه
ليس في محله في مرحله ربما لانه ليس مؤثر
هذا الحزم فدخل الصداع هو كبير نعلم ولكن
في ظل صراع عسكري اتحدث ربما يتوجب ان
يكون هناك تدخل من جهه اخرى ام لا
داره منه او الحديث التصريحه اللي هو الذي
حدث اليوم هذا التصريح كان بامكاني يكون
في 2019
ليست الصراعات التي كانت تحدث بينهم كحزب
امه فيما بينهم ومع الاحزاب التانيه
والتناحرات السياسيه الحاصله اذا كان
التكريس مثل هذه الفكره من الزمن السابق
لسنا كنا في هذا الوضع نحن ساعود لك
لمناقشه هذه التطورات وخاصه سنر كذلك
المحتمله ولكن بعد التفكير ببعض المواضيع
ذات الصله مشاهدينا حيث حذر الامين العام
للامم المتحده من ان الوضع الانساني في
السودان محفوف بالمخاطر وكارسي كما وصفه
مطالبا الجميع بضروره احترام القانون
الدولي وضمان سلامه وامن موظفي الامم
المتحده والعاملين في مجال المساعدات
الانسانيه نستمع
بماريوس الوضع الانساني في السودان محفوف
بالمخاطر وكارثه ندين بشده سقوط قتلى
وجرحى بين المدنيين والعاملين في المجال
الانساني واستهداف ونهب المب اني واذكر
الجميع بضروره احترام القانون الدولي
وضمان سلامه وامن جميع موظفي الامم
المتحده والعاملين في مجال المساعده
الانسانيه اؤكد مره اخرى بان الامم
المتحده تقف الى جانب شعب السودان وتقدم
دعم الكامل لجهود استعاده الانتقال
الديمقراطي وبناء مستقبل سلمي وامن
مشاهدينا قبل المتابعه نشير الى هذه
العواجل تطورات في مدينه مروي وبتحديد في
قاعده مروي عن مراسل العربيه تجدد للشبكات
داخل قاعده مروي العسكريه وحديث كذلك عن
تحليق طائرات عسكريه في سماء مدينه مروي
شمال السودان ودوي قصف مدفعي داخل قاعده
مروي العسكريه التطورات يوردها لنا مراسله
العربيه تخص مدينه مروي وبتحديد قاعده
مروي العسكريه انقلها لك في الواقع
بعجله ان كان لك تعليق عن اهميه هذه
المنطقه وخاصه تجدد الصراع بين الفتره
والاخرى في قاعده مروي بالتحديد قاعده
مروه هي قاعده استراتيجيه وقاعده
في منطقه هي منطقه سياحيه بالاضافه لانها
منطقه حدوديه مع
الجمهوريه مصر العربيه وهي ايضا مقر
للتدريبات العسكريه للطيران بشكل
خاص بين السودان ومصر وليست هنالك ارهاصات
بين مصر لها نفوس او تطلعات لان تكون تحتل
المكان لا العكس تماما لانه هنالك
اتفاقيات سابقه منذ فتره الرئيس السابق
البشير هذه الاتفاقيات تنفذ القول بانه من
يسيطر على قاعده مروي سيطره على الحدود
السودانيه المصريه على الاقل على مستوى
هذه المنطقه نعم نقدر نستطيع ان نقول ذلك
نستطيع ان نقول انه هي ليست منطقه للصراع
من اجل السيطره ولكن هي منطقه مهمه جدا
على مستوى القيادات العسكريه لابد من ان
تكون هي صافيه تماما
للجهه التي تسيطر عليها وبالتالي تعطيها
التفويض في ان تكون هي مسيطره على هذا
المنطقه فيما يطرح في المستقبل حول دور
القوات العسكريه على الحدود السودانيه
للمبعوث الاممي الى السودان فولكرم بيرس
القوتان
في مواجهه عنيفه مباشره بينهما منذ صباح
السبت
والى الان يبدو هنالك حشد
لبعض من الشات ولكن
بلا شكل مواجهه بين قوتين مسلحتين او
جيشين
بشكل اساسي في العاصمه في الخرطوم
ومع غلق المطار واغلب الجسور وقتال الشديد
في مناطق المحاديه
للمطار وكذلك المقر العسكريه والمقر
المختلفه لقوات الدعم السريع والجيش حول
الخرطوم وقتال شديد في دارفور
وفي سالجي
والمناطق المركزيه في جنوب دارفور
اكثر من 180 شخصا من المدنيين الجرحوا
خلال ايام الثلاثه الماضيه
واكثر من
الف او اعداد كبيره من القتلى
والجرحى من ضمنهم
ثلاثه
زملاء عملوا مع برنامج الغذاء العالمي
قتلوا بينما كانوا يقدمون الخدمات الشعب
السوداني في دارفور
القتال المستمر
وبالشكل مستمر
ومن الصعب ان نعرف الى
موازنه القوى
وبدعم للشركاء من المنطقه بذلت جهودا
لاقناع قاده الطرفين
لوقف اطلاق النار واتفاقي على
ايقاف انساني مؤقت
لتمكين رجالي والنساء والاطفال السودانيين
للذهاب الى الاماكن امنه
هو الحصول على مؤن من اجل افطاريه رمضان
ما يتناولونه ويشربونه هو لمن يرغب
بالذهاب الى المستشفى
وانا على تواصل مستمر مع قاده الطرفين
الجنرال البرهان والجنرال الحميتي
ومساعديهما
على وقف اطلاق النار الانساني ثلاث ساعات
وتطبقه بشكل جزئي مع تقليل اعمالي العنفلي
بضع ساعات خلال الليل
اتفقها مره اخرى على وقف اخر لثلاث ساعات
اليوم
من الساعه الرابعه بتوقيتنا لغايه الساعه
السابعه بتوقيتنا
التوقيت هنا والساعه السابعه واربعين
دقيقه مساء
ولكن القتال استانا فقد نهايه الوقت
ولا اسمع الا الكثير من الاصوات في الخارج
ولكنها اوقات الصلاه
واتمنى ان
يقل القتال في الليل نحن نشهد الطرفين
لوقف اطلاق النار فورا والسماح بوصولي
العمال الانسانيين
كما
طالبنا الا طرفين باحترام
فيديو
الحاجه الى حمايه المؤسسات الامنيه
والسفارات العمى الانسانيين والمنشات
الطبيه
برنامج الغذاء العالمي مع خزانه
مكاتبها
كلها علاقات
بين النيران الطرفين ودمرت
خلال 48 ساعه الماضيه
وهذا يجعله من الصعب ان لم يكن مستحيلا
للوكالات الانسانيه لتقديمي المساعدات في
دارفور ومناطق اخرى
كما ان المطارات مغلقه وليس بساحه الدخول
او الخروج وبالتالي لا يمكن ايصال المان
وبرنامج الغذاء العالمي اعلن عن مؤقت
لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه الى دارفور
وكافه العمليات اليوميه
اوقفت الان استطيع ايصال موظفينا
مكاتبهم عنها
وفي بعض الاحيان
شديده ربما اختمه بجمله واحده حول جهود
الدوليه الامين العام
الافريقيه ايضا عقد جلسات طارئه يوم الاحد
ويطالب الا طرفين بوقف النيران والتفاوض
من اجل التواصل اوقف اطلاق النار والعوده
الى
الظروف السلميه
ونحن نتعاون مع ايجات والاتحاد الافريقي
والاليه الثلاثيه هنا في الخرطوم وكذلك
على صعيد المقرات وهنالك دول اقليميه اخرى
مجامعه الدول العربيه ايضا عرضت
لن تلعب دور الوساطه وهذا مرحب به ولكن
هنالك صعوبات تخص في امكانيه الوصول الى
البلاد ولن يكون من السهل ووصولي
الوسطائي الى هنا
والطرفان المتقاتلان
لا يعطون انطباع بانهم بالتوصل الى اي
سلام قريبا
وكل واحد يطالب بطرف الاخر
بالاستسلام
وهذا
لا يبدو على انه
يعبر عن اي استعداد
لتقبل
جهود الوساطه
شكرا لهذه انا
اتحاد الافريقي
كل هذه الجهود كيف يتم التمسويق بينها
وكذلك امكانيه
التحدث كثيرا
ولا احد سيتمكن من الدخول الى السودان
الان
وممثل
نتحدث تمام كما تحدثوا الان عبر الوسائط
الرقميه
سبيل اخر
لا نستطيع التحرك ومن صعب جدا حتى اخراج
الموظفين بعض المناطق خاصه الخرطوم
الذين هم عالقنا في مناطق القتال الصعب
اخراج المنازلهم اتواجه قسطا مستمرا
وليتم كذلك الا من خلال وقف اطلاق النار
وبالتالي نتمكن عقد اجتماعات
مباشره ولكن هناك جهود منسقه اعلى صعيدي
المقرات
من الجانبيه او المتحده هنا وكذلك امانتي
والاتحاد الافريقي
طلال الحاج
شكرا عليه حاططك انا طلع الحج من قناه
العربي والحدث
نحن تفهم كل هذه الجهود الدوليه والعربيه
والافريقيه من اجل التوسط
للتواصل الى واقفه اطلاق النار واستنى في
الحوار بين الاطراف
ولكننا نستمر بسماع
الناريه من قبل طرفين حتى اليوم السيد
يوسف عزت المستشاره السياسي
تحدث مع قناه العربيه وقال وانا اقتبس بان
الوقت قد حان للقتال وليس للمبادرات
كما قال
بانهم بشكل كامل على التلفزيون او مقاله
تلفزيوني وراديو في الخرطوم
وكذلك مطار الخرطوم منذ يوم امس وان
الحكومه او الجيش الحكومه
ولا حتى يحاول السيطره عليها
في ظل مثل هذه البيانات واتوقع ان اجري
مقابله مع البرهان لاحقا اليوم
والمزيد من التصريحات الناريه من جانبه
فقد اسم حمدته انه متمرد وسوف يحاكم في
المحاكمه اذا ما اعتقل او امسك بهم في وجه
مثل هذه البيانات اي امل لدينا من اجل
التوصل
الى حل سياسي لهذه الازمه عبر الحوار
والعوده
الى العمل او العمل الانتقاليه
الديمقراطيه
هذه هي التصريحات الناريه
الغرض منها الاهداف الاعلاميه
والتلفزيونيه
وربما جذب المتابعين
وفي نفس الوقت نعم اعتقد بان هذه البيانات
تعبر عما قلت فهي لا
تعبر
عن الطرفين
وخصمين
يدعوان الى اتوسط من التوصلي الى حل مساله
سياسيه انا شخصيا وزملائي على ارضي هنا
وكذلك من الاتحاد الافريقي نحن لسنا في
طور عمليه التوسط من اجل العوده الى
العمليه السياسيه
او التوسط
من اجل حل الدائم ما اقوم به خلال اليومين
الماضيين هو محاوله
التوصلها الى وقف اطلاق نار لثلاث ساعات
يوميا
واذا ما نجحنا في ذلك
وسنستمر يوم غد بجهودنا من اجل هذا الوقت
الانسان لاطلاق النيران
ونبدا بخطواتنا من هناك وبلا لقوات على
الارض
القوات المدنيه والاطراف السياسيه
والاحزاب السياسيه
والجمعات المسلحه
في اتفاق جيوبا الملك يدعم ذلك وفيما خصل
الجنرال البرهان وحماتي
فانا اتحدث معها مع عبر الهاتف
عبر الوساطه الالكترونيه
فقد استجاب بشكل ايجابي لهذا الوقف
الانساني ولكن
هذه ليست نهايه القتال
بل هي فقط ايقاف مؤقت من اجل اغراض
الانسانيه انا كمثل اممي
ومثل لالمين العام فهذه هي الاولويه
القصوى الان امل العوده الى العمليه
السياسيه
والى حل دائم فهذا الشيء
نامل ان نلحق ونحن وشركائنا الاقليميين
وكذلك طرف السودانيه حققه لاحقا
كبيره من التعززات العسكريه في ضواحيها
الخرطوم في شمال الشرق والجنوب خليكم ايها
المعلومات حول ذلك
كما هنالك تقارير
او تواصل الاجتماعي تعليقات حول مقتل
حميدتي اليوم تقول انك على اتصال
مستمر به وبجنرال برهان فهلك تؤكد لنا
تحدثت معه خلال ساعه القيل الماضيه او انه
على الاقل على قيد الحياه وهل تعرفوا اين
مكانه
لم اتحدث معه لانني كنت في مجلس الامن
واجتماعات اخرى خلال ساعات القله الماضيه
ولكنني لم اسمع اي انباء
حول مقتل اي من القاده
من الطرفين اليوم وليست لدي اي معلومات
حول سؤال اذا طرحتيه حول تعزات القوات من
اي من الاجانبين
ونحن عميان في وجه كوري لذلك نحن جالسون
في منازلنا وتلقى نفس الانباء التي تردكم
ونحاول تهدئه الامور هنا في الخرطوم
وفي منطقه اخرى من السودان
هذا ولكن الوضع الحالي للمعارك اي طرف حسب
تقييمات المتحده الذي هو المسيطره والذي
هي لدى الطويله وكل ما تشهدونه الان وما
يجري من قبل هذه الجنرالين حل ارتقى اي
منهما الى مستوى جرائم حرب
انا لست مراسل حرب هنا بل انا مسؤول اممي
ولا استطيع ان اقيمه حتى وان رغبتم من هو
المسيطر هنا كما قلت في مقدمه وفي كلماتي
بان الوضع متقلب جدا ولا استطيع ان ارى من
هنا ولا حتى اي احد من زملائي لا استطيع
ان نتحرك لا نعرف من المسيطر على المطار
على سبيل المثال ولا حتى المشاه العسكريه
اما السؤال حول اي من الاعتداءات ولا شك
بان هنالك اعتداءات هل ارتقت منها الى
جرائم حرب فهذا القرار ان يعود الى مؤسسات
مختلفه مثلا
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ولكنني استطيع
ان اقول بان
هنالك انتهاك لمقار ومنشات الام المتحده
وان المنظمات الدوليه لم تحصل على الحمايه
وان المدنيين غير محميين ايضا
قلت بانك تتواصل مع قاده الطرفين عبر
الهاتف هل كان هناك تواصل فيما بينهما
علامه الاسبوع الماضي
عن التواصل الى اي شيء
بهذا القدر كنا في متابعه لهذه الكلمه
بدايه لفولكر بيرتز المبعوثه الاممي الى
السودان وفيما بعد تلقى كذلك اسئله واجاب
عليها هو تحدث عن انه في اتصال مستمر مع
حماتي وكذلك مع البرهان مع حفظ الالقاب
قال بانه في الوقت الراهن المطارات تمنع
وصول المساعدات وتمنع حتى وصول الوسطات ان
كانت هناك وسطات اكد بانه في تواصل مستمر
مع الجهات التي تطرح حلول تهدئه ان كان
الاتحاد الافريقي تحدث كذلك عن الثلاثيه
السودانيه تحدث عن مجموعه كبيره من
الاطراف ولكن قال يتعذر حضور مبعوثين او
وسطات او اي فرق للداخل السوداني ويتعذر
كذلك حتى وصول المساعدات للداخل السوداني
على كل انسان نتابع كل هذا ولكن نناقشه
ربما في نشرات اخرى نذكر ببعض الاخبار في
نهايه هذه الساعه فالقتال بين القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع
مازال مستمرا وسرعان ما تداولات الصحف
العربيه والغربيه اخبار الازمه السودانيه
الراهنه لتاخذ جوله مع ابرزه عناوين الصحف
الغربيه ونعود
صحيفه وولشي جان الامريكيه عنون صراع مميت
على السلطه بين اكبر جنرالين في السودان
الصحيفه تقول ان الفشل في انهاء القتال
بسرعه ومعاوده المحادثات مع القاده
المدنيين قد يدفع السودان مره اخرى
للانزلاق الى حرب اهليه وفقه محللين اما
صحيفه التلغراف البريطانيه فعنونه حرب
بوتين انفجرت في السودان السودان يتصدع
تحت تاثير المرتزق الروس وقد يتم ربط قوات
الدعم السريع بمجموعه فاغنر التي قيل انها
ساعدت في تدريبهم وتجهيزهم قد تواجه تشاد
واريتريا وجنوب السودان طوفانا من
اللاجئين ما يزيد من صراعاتهم الداخليه
الى صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه تحت
عنوان السودان يخشى من حرب اهليه بعد
انفجارات تهز العاصمه القتال في دارفور
عنصر قابل للاشتعال والصراع تعد دارفور
موطنا للعديد من الجماعات المتمرده التي
قد تنخرط في القتال صحيفه لوفيغرو
الفرنسيه عنونه التنفس بين العسكريين يجعل
الخرطوم تغرق في الفوضى على الرغم من
الدعوات العديده للهدوء من المجتمع الدولي
والقوى السياسيه السودانيه لا يبدو ان ايا
من الطرفين مستعد للتفاوض مصدر دبلوماسي
غربي في الخرطوم صرح للصحيفه بوجود عده
محاولات اقليميه ودوليه للمصالحه لكن
الامر معقد فالطرفان منخرطان في اسلوب
اللفظي وعسكري واحد
هذا مشاهدينا وكانت دانت نقابه اطباء
السودان الصراع على السلطه بين طرفي
النزاع مع خروج مستشفيات عده عن الخدمه
تماما ابرزها مستشفى الشعب التعليمي
والخرطومه التعليميه وقالت النقابه ان قصف
المرافق الصحيه يعد انتهاكا واضحا للقانون
الدولي الانساني وللمواثيق ذات الصله
واختم معك دكتور اسامه مع كل ما يحدث
وخاصه المساعدات التي لا يمكن ان تصل هل
من حلول متوفره في داخل السوداني هل تعتقد
بان هذه المعضله قادره ان تحل في هذا
الوقت صعب
بالتاكيد المعضله صعبه ولكن هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي
وانا كذلك مجموعه اسئله كثيره ولكن الوقت
انتهى مع الاسف
ما وراه كثير خاصه نحن نعرف البند السابع
في مواقع مختلفه من العالم استوقفتني كذلك
بعض التصريحات لفولكر
سنعود لهذه التصريحات سنعود لهذه التغطيه
ولكل هذه التطورات تطورات تخص ليس فقط
الخرطوم ولكن تصريحات من جانب الدعم
السريع وتصريحات كذلك من جانب الجيش
السوداني وسنعود ربما يوم غدا لكلمه
هذه الساعه انتهت مشاهدينا اول شكرك اولا
الدكتور اسامه احمد المصطفى الكاتب المحلل
في شؤون الافريقيه هذه الساعه انتهت
مشاهدينا ولكن تغطيه العربيه دائما مستمره
لمتابعه التطورات فداخل السوداني بعد قليل
ليال الاختيار تكمل معكم هذه التغطيه
ابقوا معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات